hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and behind
you is a ghostly presence watching you
it's watching and waiting and it smells
vaguely of your favorite cheese
it's watching and it's waiting and it's
going to cast a spell on you to move
your hand to the like button just below
this video
and then it's going to move your hand to
the subscribe
button but only if you have not
subscribed before
haha you will not catch me out here once
it has done that it will give you a
faintly
cheesy massage as you sit back relax and
we discuss episodes 61 and 60
no sixth oh no it's episode 60 and
karapika melody and leorio are finished
with their arc so they're doing the
awkward thing of just wandering off to
do the thing they decided to do
it's weird having two characters who
started as part of the core team that
just sort of turn up and disappear while
these two smaller kids do their thing
there
have been a lot of times where i've
looked at the way this series is written
and thought
i could have written this not because
i'm any better but because i have the
same writing style
tagashi seems to be a pantser rather
than a planner he creates based on what
he thinks would be cool at the time and
just writes the story in no meaningful
order which sounds judgmental but as i
said i do it myself
liam has often commented on the random
order in which i write and how i jump
back and forth in episode content
tagashi and i follow our
own rhythm we look at the story and
think oh you know what be interesting
here
every piece of auction knowledge i can
find well actually i don't do that
tagashi did and that's what i mean by
panting rather than planning he flies by
the seat of his pants and follows what's
interesting
creating a three main character plot
line then deciding that actually two of
them need to go away because they have
no purpose in the main story while
taking the weird skateboarding
white-haired kid whose skateboard we
haven't seen in weeks and weeks and
months and months then detailing out his
entire family
and then having a farmyard member turn
up just to go back home because he
didn't have the finances to interrupt
the story because the story was in fact
more interesting going a different way
is exactly
how a panther writes it's incredible
that definable arcs exist
actually with that in mind and probably
the reason the series works
if shigarshi knows how to do anything
it's when to shut down his wacky ideas
he can tell when they're about to go too
far or when they have gone too far and
that's the really lucky thing and
probably why this series is so
successful
but enough about style let's meet new
people whose names i'm going to forget
and actually discuss the episode
so kurapika and leorio are gone and that
leaves gone
and kilwa to once more surprise an adult
with how quickly they learn
you know what they need a checklist they
need a checklist on how to become the
best whatever it is they want to be and
to just get there and make things easier
for everyone else they get judged every
time based on something it would take
them a day to learn and frankly would
make things much easier and less
repetitive if they just wrote
a cv and carried that around with them
actually there was something interesting
here too
kiwa called himself a hunter something
he can't prove he needed to be a hunter
to play the game as far as i know though
that may have just been a standard thing
you must be this powerful and this
insane to play jumping around as i am
want to do
zephyr was going off to be a hunter
okay doing what will we ever see him
again is he going to bargain his way
through the trials it's just such an odd
ending to a character we saw maybe five
times will he just get killed at the
first step
i'll be honest i really don't want to
now that we've left the hunter exam
return to it it feels like such a
backstep in an otherwise constantly
forward rolling rock
i have fond memories of the exam i just
no
thanks piggy leaving what's his name i
don't remember i never remember horse
cow
i don't i i don't know i know it's not
chicken because that's wing and it's not
fish boy cause that's sushi
like i said he's turned up failed at
everything he intended ate a delicious
looking meal and
is now headed back home good for him oh
here's the thing
what's with that cat every time someone
fails or at least
in the two times i've seen it there's
been a cat and the focus of the scene
has talked to it does this mean farm boy
isn't so evil or that he feels good with
a full meal in his stomach
or is that cat the true meaning of
christmas i just don't know
but i love a metaphor and hate
coincidence so i'll be keeping an eye
out for that cute feline back to tests
again
and i'm grateful we didn't have to go
through the full testing process this
time
we've done it more than enough and we
know the outcome you know obviously we
know what the outcome will be
going through kilowatt's process was a
good way for us to remember that he
thinks he knows everything and that he
overthinks almost literally every aspect
of his life despite saying that his
father would hate that he's doing what
he's doing
deciding to go against the family is
something he's done again
and again and it's been fascinating the
times at which his training have come up
and how they've impacted him
i mean he was tortured with electricity
so much that he can make his aura
electricity that's hardcore but for his
dad to tell him not to take risks and
for him to continue to take them
requires this young character to step
outside of his comfort zone
so every time he overthinks that's him
trying to anticipate what that next step
away from his family will be
meanwhile gone is instinctively taking
in the information and just doing what
needs to be done
ostensibly not thinking at all though
you know my stance on that
speaking of my stance on that i wonder
whether he just struggles with
overwhelming quantities of information
that he doesn't need all at once
because i'll be honest while i somewhat
understood the mechanics of the game
individually
i did not take them all in as she was
explaining them i would say i'm a fairly
intelligent individual but the speed at
which they were being explained combined
with the emotional importance of what
was happening combined with what i
imagine would have been a sensationally
overwhelming situation
and it looks like he was actually taking
things in his stride finding out that
his dad wrote the game is pretty cool
but also finding out that his dad meant
for him to die here if he wasn't good
enough is
i mean thanks pah not only that but he
can't leave unless he finds
a very specific item we'll see what that
item is an easter egg i wonder if gonz
the only one who could ever actually
finish the game as it is given that
information
and now of course the importance of the
contract becomes clear
anything that comes out of the game
belonging to old main is important
because those items can only exist a
certain number of times in those forms
before they're gone and can't be used so
the players are hired to essentially
collect
multiples of the items in a massively
multiplayer rpg
and bring the items to the guy who hired
them which is asking a hell of a lot
especially since they'd be trapped there
if they don't find enough of look to a
certain degree i'm exactly like gone
i learn as i play we've moved into an
arc that works well for me because i
love rpgs both
computer and tabletop and i'm going to
be in theory
understanding the rules of engagement
more than i would have
anything else we'll see how close to my
experiences the game gets
anyway let's go to episode 61
oh goody a creepy girl child watching
the best friends while they have a
heartfelt moment of declaring their love
for each other which of course is not
them declaring their love for each other
in full
view because that would be embarrassing
mom
cut it out who is she why
is she what is it about kids with
flouncy skirts and pigtails and red eyes
that just looks so
creepy why is that a trope how did i
know before anything else happened that
she was going to be a problem
even before she said anything i don't
like her i don't like her one [ __ ]
should i at least
with melody i could be lulled into a
sense of kindness and warmth from her
despite the danger she poses as an
individual with this kid only darkened
hallways and
evil and nursery rhymes slow to horror
levels which you know what
suits kilwa really well speaking of
suiting kiwa really well
that moment of dark assassin and tension
that scared off dudebrah in the
beginning
that was cool not just that this is
killah in his natural habitat not that
kind of cool but the
this is the way we're going to show
kilwa's emotions from now on cool the
art involved i loved it
the down the barrel look that centered
all the darkness on him it's hot
more please then contrast that
immediately with the pastel art of the
end of the episode where the two discuss
their love
and the close-up on eyes again the
absence of emotion versus the abundance
of it was really heightened in this
episode and really lent itself to the
continuing of kilowatt's move away from
his traditional family values of killing
without emotion
there have been little touchstone
moments throughout the series of the
relationship between gon
and kilwa the biggest was the entire
episode of gone taking kilwa home
to meet the family on whale island but
the next biggest for kilwa i think was
gone saying tequila i'm worried about
the spell on you kilwa was so taken off
guard by god's care that he agreed to do
something that kilwa on his own would
not have done and
given even i thought that what was
happening was a trap
still do in fact it was god's
willingness to take a risk for his
friend that made all the difference in
that scene and that led to the entire
episode
ending where gon was apologizing for his
behavior and his inability to sacrifice
his own moral standpoint about his
father
to save his friend it was a boundary
balancer that reminded us
or told us really what gone's priorities
are specifically in that moment we found
out that
kiwa and jing are really close in
importance to gone
close enough that gone had to think
really hard about his response and that
we didn't get to see
his face until they'd walked away killua
didn't even think about the importance
of the spell on himself because
he wants to help his friend they are
each other's blind spots and it looks
like creepy kid is coming in behind him
it was really exciting to hear kilwa say
that killing's bad why
because it means that when he does it it
means he's doing it from a place outside
a moral stance
from the kid who killed two guys way
back during the hunter exam just because
his emotions were running hot after a
basketball match
to a kid who's reflecting on his own
behaviors and deciding where his moral
code sits
it's interesting to see these two
psychopaths discuss moral code and
decide where they sit on it because if
you listen to what gon said it wasn't
that he had a problem necessarily with
the concept of killing but with the idea
that his dad deliberately designed a
game where the intent is to kill
gon hasn't actively if i'm remembering
correctly tried to kill
gosh it's been a long journey so he
probably has but i don't know that he
has actively tried to kill
anyone he wants his dad to be like him
or
he wants to be like his dad and if his
dad is creating games
where the mechanics mean the fastest way
to win is to kill what would that say
about gone
how aware of himself and aware of his
own proclivities is he
that's the new question i'd say he's
fairly aware of what he is especially
when we reach back to the hunter exam
and him
having to figure out what he would do in
the important situation but it's less of
a question now of what he is
and more a question of what he wants to
be and that's huge
the development that has taken place
over these three arcs has been
phenomenal
and we get to see that as we move into
this one and because we want to get into
that as soon as possible that's it from
me
if you enjoyed this deep dive into
writing style friendship and creepy
creepy kids click here
here here and visit the discord to
discuss things more
oh like and subscribe too that helps us
know that you want more content as
delicious as these marshmallows